it's great to welcome back to the
program today Shane Dickson Cavanaugh
who is a staff reporter with The
Oregonian in Portland you might remember
that he recently joined us to talk about
a story that he's been following for
some time now involving Saudi nationals
who in the United States are accused of
crime sometimes arrested and they
disappear and he'll tell us what we mean
by disappear specifically before they
actually face justice so Shane first of
all great to have you back on catch us
up on what we discussed last time to get
everybody up to speed if you will David
thanks so much for having me back on
your show so as you mentioned for the
last few months I've been working on an
investigative series here at the
Oregonian looking into cases where Saudi
nationals
most of them attending university here
in the United States have been charged
with serious crimes ranging from
manslaughter to rape to possession of
child pornography and these individuals
a large number of them have managed to
disappear while facing prosecution
essentially these individuals have been
charged with crimes they end up posting
bail have been retained private
attorneys and then as they're moving
close to trial a number of these
individuals suddenly go missing and a
number of them we've been able to track
back to Saudi Arabia so some of the
questions I asked you last time and the
answers were some form of we're looking
into that include what do we know about
what American authorities know about
this what do we know about the sort of
financial or sort of socio political
status of these individuals in Saudi
Arabia and so it's sort of to try to
understand the contours of what may be
going on what have you learned as your
investigation has continued since we
last talked about this yeah a good place
to sort of start with that question is
to just sort of state out front that
what got us looking into these cases
originally was a single case here in
Portland
we learned that federal law enforcement
who looked into a Saudi national here in
Portland who disappeared before his
manslaughter trial in 2017 federal law
enforcement concluded that they believe
the Saudi Arabian government had played
a role in orchestrating this individuals
escape from prosecution
this individual was picked up in a black
SUV outside of his home he cut his ankle
monitor and then federal law enforcement
believed he was given an illicit
passport and possibly smuggled out of
the United States on a private plane so
that's what got us looking into whether
or not there are other cases like this
one here in Oregon and around the
country and in the last few months we
have now documented nearly 30 cases
where similar similar circumstances have
unfolded and so one of the questions
we've been raising from the beginning is
whether or not the Saudi Arabian
government might be involved in more of
these escapes and also the question of
has the US government known about this
and in answer to your question
our most recent story that came out two
weeks ago in partnership with ProPublica
the non-profit investigative news
website who helped us on this most
recent story we found that the
Department of Homeland Security and the
FBI have since around 2008 known about
the Saudi Arabians students disappearing
from the United States and had
identified Saudi operatives here in the
u.s. that had helped a number of these
students escape from the US is there
anything that you've uncovered so far so
okay to be clear authorities American
authorities became aware of some of
these cases presumably I want to make
sure I'm understanding correctly we
believe after the fact not as these
individuals were facing prosecution
correct what we what we were able to
find is that back in 2008 analysts with
the Department of Homeland Security
began
looking into a number of cases that had
come up or come to their attention where
Saudi nationals mostly college students
were charged with crimes and then were
disappearing from the United States so
they began looking into this phenomenon
and quickly determined that they
believed that members of the Saudi
Arabian government working through the
Saudi cultural mission in Washington DC
were assisting these suspected you know
suspected criminals facilitating their
escape from the United States and there
was actually a report on this produced
by the Department of Homeland Security
back in 2008 which they then gave to the
FBI but it appears that that report was
never distributed more widely throughout
the intelligence community here in the
US and what we also learned through our
reporting is that you know this issue
has come up time and time again on the
radars of federal law enforcement
officials in the FBI Homeland Security
the State Department has been aware of
this yet nobody in the US government has
really taken up the issue seriously now
there's no reason to believe at this
point in time that there's any American
complicity in this right or at least
it's it at this point in time you've not
found evidence of that is that correct
what do you mean by complicity well I
don't know what do you what should I
mean in other words is there anything
you've uncovered so far that suggests
that given that there is no extradition
treaty with Saudi Arabia given that many
of these individuals have or are able to
get access to resources to get out that
don't involve commercial flights and
they involve you know potentially false
passports do you have any reason to
think that American authorities are
aware of the potential flight risk of
some of these individuals as the cases
are unfolding and either look the other
way or even potentially assist in
getting them out of the country that's
actually a really great question David
and I think at this time we don't have a
real clear understanding on that matter
what we can say is that you know this
has been an
that's been on the radar of the federal
law enforcement for a debt you know up
to a decade they knew that this was
happening and you know it appears that
with during that time period where a
number of these individuals were
escaping justice in the United States
the US government never made an issue
about it or even confronted the Saudi
Arabian government an ally of the u.s.
about this issue do you have what are
the logistics at the sort of individual
case level in other words do you have
reason to believe that the Saudi
individuals know in advance that if you
get into trouble here's who you have to
call is it that where is the bail money
coming from are they getting themselves
bailed out and later contacting Saudi
assistance or is this something that
Saudi the Saudi consulate for example
might be handling from the beginning of
what what do you know about those
details right so I think to answer that
question the first thing we that we have
to sort of point out or illustrate is
that there has been a tremendous influx
in the number of Saudi students studying
in the United States in the last decade
plus starting in about 2005 most of
these students in the US are recipients
of a government scholarship program by
the Saudi Arabian government and one of
the things that we learned and kind of
had already known about before this
latest story came out but that the Saudi
government keeps very close tabs on all
of their students who are studying here
in the United States I mean it appears
that through the Saudi cultural mission
they sort of have a large surveillance
program to keep an eye on students just
to make sure that they're staying out of
trouble
or that they're not engaging in
political activity or that they're you
know not talking to the wrong people etc
etc so the our understanding is that
that the Saudi government has pretty
close tabs on most of their students and
so are able to find out pretty quickly
when some of them have gotten into
serious
legal trouble in almost all of the cases
that we've documented to date after an
individual gets jailed on you know on
suspicion of whatever crime the Saudi
Arabian government as a policy and
they've told us this explicitly as a
policy will post the bail money for any
individual any citizen of theirs accused
of a crime in the United States and then
also provide money for legal
representation so they don't have a you
know a public defender or something like
that so in some of these cases the
Saudis have put up substantial sums of
money for these individuals accused of
crimes you know we're talking six-figure
sums of bail money that's put up by
various consulates Saudi consulates here
in the US you know many of the ones
we've looked at here in Oregon because
we've documented a number of cases here
that's come from the closest consulate
to us in Oregon is the Saudi Arabian
consulate Los Angeles so you mentioned
some of some items that were told to you
about how this works from from Saudi
authorities but have they answered any
direct questions about the fact that
some of these individuals are
disappearing and evading justice or have
they not answered the questions related
to that it's been a little difficult
getting detailed explanations from these
Saudi embassy in Washington which has
been sort of our main point of contact
throughout this series but they have
sort of given a blanket denial that they
that their government has helped anybody
or any Saudi citizen break US laws and
escape prosecution in the United States
are there any explanations for any any
parts of this I mean in total it seems
very hard that this would apply but are
there any parts of this that if we said
let's be less cynical skeptical whatever
term you want to apply that there are
some some kind of innocent explanation
for some parts of this well I think
maybe the most
if we could even call it an innocent
explanation you know I think it's a it's
a matter of maybe there is that the
Saudi Arabian government has very little
faith in the US criminal justice system
or there might be a sort of ingrained
belief especially after 9/11 that you
know Arab men in the US who are accused
of certain crimes are not going to get
you know a fair shake in the US criminal
justice system and you know instead of
taking a chance of going to trial and
facing years in prison they're making
the decision to help these individuals
escape and return to Saudi Arabia I mean
that could be the most innocent
explanation but it would still require a
foreign government an ally of the United
States subverting are you the US justice
system and also violating a number of
what US and international laws has the
Trump administration been presented with
this I know you've been in touch with
some senators and if so what have they
said about it well at this point in time
it's it's a but it is you know
explicitly clear that the Trump
administration does know about our
reporting and our findings senators in
Washington have raised this question
multiple times with various agencies in
the Trump administration they've
responded finally after ignoring a
number of our questions and queries
throughout this process because we've
written more than a dozen stories on
this now so they're aware of this
they're aware of our findings and
they're aware that we now know that the
US government prior to the Trump
administration has known about this you
know both in the George W Bush
administration and under President
Barack Obama however now that this has
been revealed it's sort of in the Trump
administration's Court to do something
about it or choose not to do anything
and at this point in time it doesn't
appear based on everything we know that
they're particularly interested in
raising this issue yeah
I mean this now starts to get more into
Saudi US relations but there is this
question which I mentioned of an
extradition treaty with Saudi Arabia
which is not currently in place would I
mean imagining that that was put in
place would that mostly preempt the
utility of getting these individuals out
to Saudi Arabia or would that only deal
with part of the issue well I think that
you know the idea of Saudi Arabian
government agreeing to an extradition
treaty with the United States is just I
mean not even a an idea worth
entertaining it's never going to happen
but clearly the without an extradition
treaty once these individuals are able
to get out of the United States and
return home
there is really no mechanism in place to
have these fugitives brought back to the
US unless they end up going to a country
where the US has an extradition treaty
say one of these individuals goes back
home to Saudi Arabia and then several
years later decides to go on a vacation
in Europe somewhere they could get
picked up and extradited back to the US
that way but otherwise if they get back
to Saudi Arabia for the time being there
seems to be little the u.s. can do if
they don't want to apply political or
diplomatic pressure on the Saudis and
you know up until now they've chosen not
to do that yeah and no indication as
you're suggesting that that piece is
going to change any any time soon really
excellent with that with that point
there I mean the State Department in a
letter to Senator Ron Wyden who's a
senator from Oregon who was asking the
State Department about you know the all
of these Saudis disappearing and
returning home the State Department
wrote Y in the letter a couple of months
ago and essentially said that there was
nothing that they could do about this
they basically said it was a law
enforcement issue not a diplomatic issue
which is false because the State
Department there's a number of things
the State Department could do on this
particular issue but you know the sort
of implicit
from the letter was that they weren't
going to do anything we've been speaking
with Shane Dixon Cavanaugh staff
reporter with The Oregonian in Portland
Oregon Shane really appreciate you
getting us up to speed and continue the
good work on this I really appreciate
your interest in this issue